[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have happy
Valentine's Day and on this the sexiest
time of a year I'm spending my time at
Alma con where there's a lot of sexy
cats around here and I managed to get
one of them in my room right now
isn't that right sexy guests that's
right Pookie ah little kuriboh you're
not mockery oh no they couldn't get us
so they sent a replacement I don't think
this is going to work the same if it
gets weird we'll just stop okay so see
how it is the sexiest time of the year
we of course partake in many okay I got
weird yeah but I really think we have
something go back to d4 sigh well we'll
still get on with this list if there's
anything that I've noticed over the
years is that the greatest couples are
usually the strangest couples the whole
idea of the romantic couple that meets
love at first sight
carried off on the horse and lived
happily ever after
yeah that's pretty much bullshit now
today's love stories are weird quirky
odd out of the norm because people are
waking up and realizing that how reality
is and you know what there's nothing
wrong with that people are weird and
love is weird
it makes us do crazy things and rather
than be ashamed of it it makes more
sense to celebrate it so what I plan to
do today is count down the top 11
strangest but also most lovable couples
that media has ever given us they're the
couples that didn't follow the fairytale
road and instead wrote their own stories
breaking the mold and making there's
most memorable and unique so get ready
this is the top 11 strangers and kind of
by obvious connections greatest come
[Music]
number eleven
Jessica and Roger from Who Framed Roger
Rabbit definitely one of the original
odd couples as quite clearly they're
polar opposites one is a sexy gorgeous
looking hot woman
the other is well a rabid and sure
enough there's just something about him
that drew her to him but what is it the
movie is surprisingly very vague about
it
the only information we ever get out of
her is what do you see in a guy it makes
me laugh and that's it and maybe that's
what strangely kind of draws us to this
couple there is this mystery there is
the strange question how do they make it
work how do they actually find each
other attractive what's the cool thing
about is you realize maybe a good beyond
that maybe Jessica just is looking for
her polar opposite I mean she doesn't
seem particularly funny or goofy or have
a lot of energy or anything so kind of
makes sense that she would go for
someone like Roger Roger if you realize
never really looks at her like a sex
object where everybody else does he
doesn't see a scorching-hot woman he
wants to get in bed with he just sees a
very kind loving person that he wants to
marry while everybody else in the movie
either howls at her doesn't trust her
even treats her like a bad guy roger is
always there to show his love and
support and that's pretty cool this is
one of the few relationships where the
vagueness is actually what makes it so
intriguing but not on-screen together
for very long but that just makes you
wonder all the more what they're doing
to make this relationship work I mean
they're clearly happy neither one ever
has a bad word to say about the other
Jessica even manages to put a lot on the
line breaking her husband's heart so
that he can continue to work now granted
maybe she could have told him that going
into all this but I don't know the one
element this movie that's actually not
that great is the mystery I rot eclis
she I wonder who did it
what's the reason why these two love
each other is a genuine mystery one we
enjoy trying to figure out it's a
strange combination that for some reason
works and we always enjoyed seeing them
come together come on Roger let
[Music]
[Applause]
number ten Valley and Dawn from third
Rock from the Sun she's an alien from
outer space he is a horrible cop and
neither one ever catches on tally is
described in the alien world to be the
security officer and on top of that male
a super aggressive testosterone-filled
male so when Sally is put in a female
body she doesn't know how to react to
but the person that helped her through a
lot of it is dawn
he's a cop but he's also a scaredy-cat
he's lazy's never in control and is our
a terrible at his job Sally who knows
much more about weaponry and being a
badass is able to teach him how to be a
bit more tough while he in return can
teach her not to be so blunt
one of the things that makes him so
great is that they are such a bizarre
combination but they just enjoy each
other's company so much look at the way
she stares at him she just looks at that
guy like he's the sexiest man in the
world
and he just seems so happy that view of
a woman is giving him a chance that
he'll put up with any of those
strangeness that she puts it through
over time they form a very genuine
relationship that's based more on trust
that it would and of course the other
element that makes them such a good
couple is how forgiving they honor
there's an especially great episode
where Sally wants to pose nude for a
magazine but Don doesn't water - even
though he clearly looks at other women
another magazine is this a good thing or
a bad thing in the end it almost doesn't
even matter because each one always
finds a way and makes a compromise to
the solution and that's a pretty cool
thing that couples should do their odds
are strange and they're totally out of
control
it's a match made in the strangest
recesses of space now watch it next time
I want you to do something you don't
want to do
I'm only now doing
Theodore and Samantha from her of course
a relationship this strange and to make
it into the mix especially seeing how
one is an even human samantha is an
artificial intelligence designed to
please Theodore based around his
personality she's just supposed to do
simple stuff that most computers do with
a human touch but the AI form such a
personality that eventually he falls in
love with her and in a strange way you
can kind of see why her ability to learn
and her programming to want to continue
to learn helps her form a very genuine
personality a very likeable personality
she becomes complex she becomes smart
she becomes emotional and that just
draws our main character all the more
tore Theodore is already a very lonely
guy he almost never goes outside he just
stays in playing video games and such
and to him the most important part of a
relationship is a woman's mind well
Samantha is nothing but of mine so she
seems relatively perfect he can't see
her he can't touch her all he can do is
hear and I guess in many relationships
were couples claimed they don't listen
enough in this one that's all they can
do all building up to the climax of the
film but I won't give away but let's
just say is perfectly fitting the great
thing about this relationship is that
the total Rorschach that you can look at
and you can say oh what a charming love
story that doesn't have to center around
sex or anything like that but you can
also look at and say boy what a creepy
tale of a pathetic person that really
scared me and both have a lot of bases
and truths you know he should probably
get with a real person but at the same
time he does respect this creation as
well just her own person I get the main
ways that makes it one of the most
complex relationships ever put on film
and certainly one of the most bizarre
couples ever created who needs romancing
of the heart when you have romantic of
the mind don't you touch me
summary Perry and Lydia from the Fisher
King
he's a mentally ill homeless man she's a
socially awkward woman who's afraid of
the world perry sees so much in her
though and always watches her from afar
and when he finally gets up the courage
to ask her out
it's an uncomfortable match made in
heaven neither one can talk straight
neither one can look each other in the
eye either one can be comfortable and
they're both nervous wrecks it's almost
like watching two kids trying to figure
out what it means to go on a date at
first her shyness gets in the way and
she thinks she's never going to be good
enough for anybody that she's not
deserving and she's just going to have
her heart broken Oh Perry does what he
does best upset only this time is
efficient is over something that seems
very well-meaning and actually kind of
lovely you don't feel as wonderful as
everybody else and feeling is alone
separate as you feel you are and I think
you're the greatest thing since sliced
ranks I won't be distant I'll come back
in the morning can I'll call you feel
happy it's a great moment when these two
finally realize they can be happy and
they can be happy together even though
they're still unbelievably socially
awkward they can at least be socially
awkward together they're probably the
only two who want to understand each
other
every single time he sees her his world
is dancing that's how he sees everything
and thus understanding each other also
helps them understand themselves
building their confidence and their
strength it's weird it's uncomfortable
it's a perfect unique love that they can
call all their own
didn't give me the number
dr. girlfriend and the monarch from
Venture Brothers
he's a diabolical supervillain she
doesn't quite sound right what the hell
is that thing doing in our bed the
relationship in the show has definitely
had their ups and downs but through it
you surprisingly want to see them get
together nano Manatee how did you get
that number you like it it's a prototype
of my dr. mrs. the monarch comes to I
don't want to be picky
you're gonna trip on this wing you
always laugh at as ridiculous outfit as
patheticness and you always kind of
laugh at her strange voice but when you
would pass that there is sort of the
strange connection that really works
they get jealous of one another and they
bicker and they argue but when they do
you know it's not out of wanting to
control the other it's more out of that
they actually really do care about the
other come here and on your king's ever
expanding throne even when they do get
angry at each other there's never a
sense that it's an abusive relationship
like with Joker and Harley they just
seem angry like a lot of couples and
guess what when they come together to
work on a scheme it's like honey on um
Jackie Kennedy style gloves vicious no
separating the two definitely crazy and
by no means perfect dr. girlfriend and
the monarch are a creepy crazy caring
couple Oh God excuse me oh sorry pookums
welcome home great it's a pride my wings
with your ass
violet and Corky from fowl as much as
people love to praise the Wachowski
brothers for the matrix or Cloud Atlas
or whatever found is still in my opinion
their magnum opus not only is it a great
suspense film dewater but it has a
surprisingly believable couple in it
this movie was made in the 90s where as
I mentioned before in another review
they didn't always write gay people the
best the idea was sort of that their
gayness was their personality and not
much more but the great thing about this
couple is that they do have very defined
personalities and they have some real
on-screen chemistry a lot of people gave
the movie Flag for the one or two erotic
scenes and they're saying it was just
soft porn but to me it's no different
than when you see a straight couple
making out in the movie it's supposed to
be a little erotic but here it works
because you actually do believe they're
in love Korky is tough and determined a
little bit of a grease monkey - violet
is much more subdued but definitely has
a devious diabolical mind
together they hatch a scheme to get
revenge on her husband a crazy obsessed
mafia hitman while also managing to get
her out of her mob connections without
getting whacked and of course a million
things go wrong and the more crazy
things get the more they try to look
after the other and make sure they come
out okay and every single time one is in
trouble
the other one is always there to get
them out of the predicament there's
something so legitimately badass about
them kind of like Bonnie and Clyde only
Bonnie and Clyde Dean what's the female
quite I don't care they're just cool the
diabolical they're scheming and in many
ways they're kind of their polar
opposites one much more aggressive and
tough and the other more soft-spoken and
subdued they complement each other
perfectly in a bizarre situation that
needs a bizarre solution well when they
put their heads together they come up
with a bizarre answer mostly from being
a bizarre couple you have two
differences between youmuu's Ireland
yeah me neither
Batman and cat look if the Joker is
Batman villain is opposite Catwoman is
Batman's villainous similarity both have
a lot in common and that they both dress
up in costumes they both fight crime and
they do what they think is best for the
law while operating outside of the law
the only difference is Catwoman will
more break the law in order to get to
the greater good Batman for the most
part does she'll steal cheek lie and
destroy anybody who gets in her way
she doesn't really pick a side good or
bad she just does what she thinks is
best sometimes that means hurting bad
people sometimes that means hurting good
people Batman has a stronger ethical
code but not by much he's still crazy
enough to dress up in a costume and
operate outside of the police department
which makes him almost as crazy as
Catwoman and it's this fine line that
these two have always been walking that
brings them so close together they're on
again off again relationship has made
them impossible not to watch in the
comic in the animated series and in the
movies there's always some romantic link
to show how similar these two are it's
only in the tragic details that keep
them separate some versions like in the
cartoon they seem almost cut from the
same cloth both bridge and both fighting
for what they feel needs to be done in
the Burton movie she's a little bit more
of a psychotic forming almost a split
personality that Bruce feels he can save
just in time but the closer he gets the
more he realizes how similar they are
and that in reality maybe they both need
saving and the Dark Knight Rises they
make more of a better duo than a couple
they do legitimately kick ass and look
pretty cool together but the chemistry
and romance is more of an afterthought
well there ever a point in the movie
where they really connected and of
course in the comics it's the craziest
of relationships one can yet sometimes
knowing each other secret identity other
times not there's no denying these two
share a special bond that it's clearly
their own whether you call it an epic
love or hopelessly chaotic there's no
denying that these two give a clearer
definition to the term crazy love
almost got it
[Music]
dan and Roseanne and Alan Lotus I put
these four in the same category because
they are very similar there are two
couples that come from a very poor
upbringing have crapped constantly fall
on them all the time and week after week
always have to deal with new shit
whether from their job or their boss or
their kids or whatever they must come
from couples where the woman clearly
calls the shots at home and the man
constantly tries to keep up while
showing support
what makes both of them work so well
though is that they're both constantly
on the same page they understand one
another they finish each other sentences
as well as each other's jokes they
support one another they play with one
another they sarcastically insult one
another but always in a very loving way
any other couple would take these as
incredibly hurtful but for them it's
just everyday talk it's how they
communicate in such a bad situation and
they both understand that because at the
end of the day you clearly see they
enjoy being with each other they're
active they're energized they're silly
they're joking any time they say
something that a lot of people would
think is too harsh you realize it's just
their way of coping and saying that I
understand I'm going through the same
thing because half the jokes they make
to one another they also make about
themselves they know that not being rich
and being social outcasts is actually
okay they celebrate it it's what makes
them who they are it's what makes them
unique and even if it turns out the
neighborhood hates them they don't give
a shit they love themselves and each
other and that creates more than enough
strength to help them get through
anything they're bitter they're
sarcastic and they wouldn't have it any
other way
they're the perfect couple of couples to
be joyfully miserable Hey what's not
with the childhood boys
[Music]
[Applause]
Shrek and Fiona from the Shrek movies
not for me personally I couldn't get
much into the relationship in the first
film I mean it's okay it's not bad you
got strike as the disgusting ogre and
then Fiona as I guess sort of a
disgusting princess that sort of find
this middle ground but you got to go
through that bullshit where they
misunderstand one another and then they
have them open yeah every romantic
comedy of horse crap you see it over and
over
however in strike two you see what
happens after they get married and
they're actually a very likeable couple
in this scenario the pretty princess
becoming an ogre is a happy ending
she doesn't care how she looks because
she's found the one that she loves and
in the sequel to impress her family
Shrek is willing to give up his
appearance just like she gave up her in
order to make things right but naturally
in the end you find that not a manager
she loves him for who he is and who she
always wants him to be
they share a surprisingly really strong
chemistry they're discussing monsters
but they don't mind being disgusting
monsters as long as they have the love
for each other nothing else matters and
each of them throughout the course the
movies make sacrifices for one another
as well and when each has realized when
they've done something that's gone too
far the other is always there to quickly
forgive them well works with them is one
there straightforward shown each other
the good the bad and of course deal it's
a very new kind of fairy tale ending
that we all very much welcome it's not
the hideous monster turn into somebody
beautiful it's somebody beautiful being
turned into the hideous monster but
realizing that even in that physical
appearance there can be a beauty that
nobody else can deny Shrek and Fiona
show it's not always easy being green
but it's always romantic we're rarely
[Music]
homer and Marge from the Simpsons The
Simpsons are definitely role models for
the dysfunctional family and that they
show exactly how to be a dysfunctional
family and at the center of it it's
Homer always gained two stupid
Harebrained Schemes and Marge always
being there trying to rationalize and
keep things together both have their
very obvious faults homer being naive
and often very selfish and Marge being
too protective and not always opening up
to the real world between them though
they do show that within all this
insanity there's a connection that only
they can forge Homer always gets into
trouble and any rational woman would
have left him years ago but Wright sees
that very much like a big child he just
doesn't know any better and when he does
make an effort even if it backfires she
does see that he is trying very hard to
make that effort when he does feel sad
that he lets somebody down he feels
legitimately sad nothing about him is
phony it's just not very intelligent and
for Marge to see that in Homer
especially when most people would leave
him in a millisecond she was a very kind
and devoted heart does she forgive him
too many times probably does Homer get
in more trouble than it's worth
definitely but still at its core you see
a couple that's constantly trying why
because they love each other that much
neither one ever wants to give up on the
effort neither one ever says always only
my spouse they're not important even at
times when they're pushed to the
breaking point when they think they
might not love each other anymore all
they have to do is look in each other's
eyes and realize there was never truly
any doubt
Who am I kidding I love you more than
ever
I love you so sorry to scare you like
that babe their marriage is constantly
put into jeopardy but surprisingly every
time it is we don't want to see them
break apart despite all the insane stuff
that happens we do find they work very
well together
it is dysfunctional and it is flawed but
there's so much effort and there's so
much caring to try and make it work that
you realize that's the most important
element in all of this it's totally
ludicrous and doesn't always make a lot
of sense but hey neither does love all
the time for all the hell that these two
have put each other through you realize
the only reason they could stay together
must be out of true love hmm I got a
problem once you stop this car I'm gonna
hug you and kiss you and then I'll never
be able to let you go and the number one
strangest couple of all time is Gomez
and Morticia from The Addams Family
whether in the show the movie the comic
strip or even the cartoon one thing but
creepy and kooky Addams Family have
always gotten down is that Morticia and
Gomez absolutely love each other this is
a family that lives in the McCobb and
loved the dark and gothic they
constantly try to maim and murder each
other why because it feels good because
it's just what they enjoy they adore
living in the sick and twisted and even
with her family you find that through
all the really crazy stuff that they go
through the most important element is
always their family in the movies I
always saw a question how can these
villains possibly do them any harm when
they always harm themselves anyway what
is there to lose in fact half the time
they praise the villains for the crazy
schemes that they have but then it hit
me the one point that you don't cross
with them is family the villains always
try to separate the family and that's
always the move that goes too far and at
the center of it is gomez Morticia being
the most obsessed
couple ever it's not just loved it is
adoring one another they cannot stay
away from each other every second
they're on screen they're always
praising the other whether it's in front
of people or just on their own every
time you see them together they just
look so content like they're in heaven
just being in one another's presence and
of course they don't fit into the norm
and they do scare people and they do
make them feel uncomfortable but the
reason that the show and the movies and
everything else has been such a hit it's
because there's such a joy that they
take out of it and that joy does come
from the love that they constantly share
with one another what they have is
bizarre but it's always loving it's
always with such enthusiasm as always
with such passion whenever they do
something grotesque you can see in their
eyes they're only doing it because they
think it will please the other little
can upset them because there isn't much
to be upset about as long as they have
each other they are constantly unclouded
creepy kooky mysterious and spooky and
altogether kooky which by the way who
ever used the word boo kiya I don't get
that Gomez and Morticia are both the
strangest and most romantic couple the
world has ever seen some days no peeking
god
[Music]
and speaking of love I got a nice sexy
replacement for this sexy enough isn't
that right you picture have sweet cheeks
ah you're not breathing for about a
little kuriboh
[Music]
you